5 56 on your wednesday morning it's  driving me crazy potholes on the east  side of town  viewer ryan writes in hey the  intersection of sahara  and nellis is in bad shape on my commute  to work have to avoid hitting two  potholes says the intersection needs to  be fixed is it going to happen anytime  soon well ryan  that intersection has to be part of a 10  mile  long project started back in november  fixing up nellis from trop on the south  all the way north up to craig  and sahara certainly part of that the  only question is when is sahara going to  be fixed nevada department of  transportation spokesman tony ilya says  we are planning on replacing damaged  concrete pavement  at sahara in early july he says the  project remains on track and within the  34 million dollar budget  anticipated completion the first quarter  of 2022  ryan thanks for writing in buckle up  drive carefully please  put down that phone if there is  something driving you crazy email me  traffic 8 8newsnow.com